what is this hideous place my home we're
on the Isle of the Lost
have you ever wondered why the other
villain kids don't appear in The
Descendants movies there are plenty more
of them and the novels and the animated
TV series after all we are revealing the
real reason why these BK's didn't make
the cut keep watching to the end to
discover which of your favorites main
characters might have a secret twin
first up let's meet the three new vks
coming our way in descendants three and
their siblings who aren't appearing in
the movie Sammy's mean in the new film
we're going to meet twins squeaky and
squirmy they're the sons of mr. Smee
Captain Hook's first made in Peter Pan
we all know too much about what his twin
boys will do in the movie but we do know
that squeaky is played by Christian
country and squirmy is portrayed by Luke
Roessler and we do know that they
actually have another brother Sami who
is mentioned in the Isle of the Lost
prequel novel by Melissa de la Cruz but
it seems like he hasn't made the cut for
the movie the question is why not well
he's only mentioned briefly in the novel
as a gasps deadmau5 Hellraiser party
perhaps the filmmakers decided they've
got enough of a pirate crew and maybe
there's something important about the
twins in his third movie
keep watching to hear some more exciting
theories about that later on
Celia Faso Pierre is the other newbie k
confirms to be in the third movie she is
the daughter of dr. facile ear the
villain in The Princess and the Frog
like squeaky and squirmy Celia also has
a sibling in the descendants world that
didn't make the cut for the movies and
that's Freddy Freddy fasoli err anyone
who's watched the animated shorts in
Disney Channel's descendants wicked
world TV series will know about Freddy
fassl ear the show premiered two months
after the first movie came out Freddy
has the same fashion sense as her sister
and father with her cute little top hat
she spend a lot of time in her dad's
shop where he practices magical arts
Freddy is a dab hand at voodoo magic and
casting spells she's also a mischief
maker and a slick talker who sneaks into
auradon after maintaining her villainous
ways to begin with Freddy decides to try
being good instead Freddy
so appears in melissa della cruises
novel returned to the Isle of the Lost
this novel was published between the
first two movies she has a key role in
the plot delivering anonymous messages
to Maui Vijay and Carlos it's thanks to
these messages that the four vks
returned to the Isle to see yen Sid and
his anti-heroes Club Freddy also has her
own chapter book in the school of
secrets book series her book was
published between the first two movies
called Freddy's shadow cards it's all
about how she uses her dark magic to get
her own way that's because her dreams of
joining the acapella group at auradon
prep fall apart the question is why
doesn't Freddie appear in The
Descendants movies we reckon it's
precisely because she's had such a part
to play in the other media perhaps the
filmmakers wanted a fresh start and a
fasoli rvk that didn't have any baggage
with Celia they can do whatever they
want
[Music]
CJ ends Harriet hook Mike Freddie CJ
hook is another VK that's appeared in
the wicked world TV animation and her
own chapter book but not in the movies
CJ which is short for Calista Jane is
the daughter of Captain Hook as Captain
James Hook he shares the same initials
as his daughter
CJ's chapter book in the school of
secrets series is called CJ's treasure
chase in it she Stow's away to auradon
prep with her father's old treasure map
she sets about searching the school
while playing pranks on the AKS also
like Freddie CJ has a sibling that does
appear in the movies and that's Harry
hook member of Emma's pirate gang and
descendants - but did you also know
there's another hook sibling that's
Harriet hook who appears in Melissa
della cruises novels in Isle of the Lost
Harriet is a student at dragon hall and
the captain of her own pirate crew she
dances with Anthony Germaine at the
party at Hell Hall and she might just
have a crush on him in the novel rise of
the Isle of the Lost
we learned that Harriet is the eldest
daughter of Captain Hook with Harry and
CJ as her younger siblings so the
question is why don't CJ and Harriet
appear in the movies for CJ it's
probably the same reason as Freddy
facile ear she has a lot of baggage in
that is
since world whereas Harry has none as
for Harriet's perhaps the filmmakers
didn't want a prominent female member of
Emma's pirate gang
by choosing Harry instead they could
make it more striking at uma is a female
leader of male pirates if Harriet was
there instead there might have been more
of a power struggle between her and Emma
to leave the gang after all Harriet had
her own gang at Dragon Hall Anthony
Tremaine speaking of Harriet dancing
with Anthony Germaine
he's another --vk that appears in
melissa della cruises novels but not the
movies he is the son of Anastasia
Tremaine from Cinderella so that makes
him cousins with dizzy and step cousins
with Chad charming and it seems like he
has quite a lot in common with Chad
despite the fact that one is a BK and
one is an A K Anthony carries himself
like he's of noble blood
in fact he tries to get the inhabitants
of the isle to call him Lord Jermaine
unsurprisingly they don't we've seen in
the movies how chad is pretty arrogant
he considers himself to be more
important than his peers - we'd love to
see how these two cousins would interact
if they lived in the same place
would they be besties over their common
ground or rivals it looks like we won't
get to find out however as Anthony isn't
slated to be appearing in descendants
three so why doesn't he star in the
movies we believe it's because the
tremaine slot has already been filled by
dizzy she's a likable character and the
perfect person to be Evie's honorary
little sister there probably isn't
enough air time for any more members of
the same family Anthony doesn't have a
large role in either the Isle of the
Lost or the return of the Isle of the
Lost novels but he is part of a group of
BK's that's rotten to the core he's one
of the villain kids that refused to join
the anti-heroes Club that's the secret
organization of villain kids on the Isle
who were drawn to good more than evil
next up are a couple more BK's who
didn't join the club
Gaston Junior and Gaston the third the
twin sons of Gaston from Beauty and the
Beast also refused to join yen sid's
anti-heroes Club they're called Gaston
junior and Gaston the third Ginni Gothel
and mad Maddie are the other two who
didn't join more on them later again
we're seeing another set of twins in the
descendants world that could be very
important for a theory about one of the
main characters in the franchise stay
tuned for more on that we haven't seen
the Gaston twins in the movies yet but
we have seen their younger brother Gil
he's a member of Emma's pirate gang and
besties with Harry hook in fact in the
Junior novelization of descendants to
Gillan Harry are so close they share a
kiss this happens in the scene when the
Pirates are celebrating after Ben
announces his gift for uma the scene was
recorded for the movie - but cut from
the final version but back to Gil's
older brothers what do we know about
them they appear in Melissa della
cruises novels in Isle of the Lost
they help Evie settle into dragon Hall
and they're often shown fighting each
other in return to the Isle of the Lost
they get out put it in a scuffle with
Jay so why didn't they get chosen to
appear in the movies it could be down to
their history with Evie in the prequel
novel that book was published a few
months before the first movie came out
and maybe the filmmakers didn't have
time to explore that dynamic with Gil
they had a clean slate Matt and Matty
nog Matty is one of the villain kids
that features quite prominently and
Melissa della cruises novel returned to
the Isle of the Lost
she's the granddaughter of madam MIM the
villain from the sword in the stone
madam MIM also appears in the novel
taking on the form of a dragon to attack
our dime we learned that Matty was best
friends with MAO and they were kids they
were even considered twins because they
had matching purple hair this isn't the
twin we've been teasing though you need
to keep watching for that the two
besties grew apart as they grew up after
Mao did some mean things to Matty Matty
tried to get her revenge on mal by
pretending to be a member of the
anti-heroes Club but really she was a
spy Matty Lords mal away to be attacked
by her gang of villain kids all of whom
refused to believe they
be good Matty told Mao she hated her all
along with Ginny Gauchos help she pushed
mal into the water to be eaten by
crocodiles now gets saved but mad Matty
is still mad at her so why isn't mad
Matty in the movies while we reckon it's
because uma got in there instead after
all and now have a similar history they
were friends until mounted some mean
things to Emma and it's uma who's
seeking revenge in the films so there
isn't really room for yet another former
friend of mouth' to be hell-bent on
revenge
Jenny Gothel as we've seen mother
Goethals daughter Ginny is good friends
with mad Matty in the novel's but she
didn't make it into the films either the
question is why we think Ginny doesn't
appear in the movies because Rapunzel
doesn't explicitly have any kids in The
Descendants movies either although
Rapunzel does have a daughter called
Ruby in the wicked world animation and
another daughter called and sullen in
the school of secrets web series about
kids at our dime prep Diego De Vil we've
mentioned the anti-heroes Club a couple
of times in the context of villain kids
who refused to join but Diego de Vil did
join the club he appears in Melissa de
la Cruz's novels Isle of the Lost and
returned to the Isle of the Lost
although he only has a small part he
could have a big impact if he were
included in the movies that's because
his thought that Diego might be the son
of Cecil B Deville in the 101 Dalmatians
animated series we learned that Cruella
De Vil has a brother called Cecil B
Deville so if the theory were true that
would make Diego the nephew of karela
and therefore he be Carlos's cousin he's
described as being tall and skinny with
a black and white mohawk haircut he also
appears in the descendants of video game
wouldn't it be neat to see what Carlos
would be like with a cousin we're
finishing up with another member of the
anti-heroes Club and keeping with a
family theme our last villain kid might
just be related to one of the main
characters it's finally time for that
twin theory we've been teasing
throughout this video hatee hatee
appears in the novel returned to the
Isle of the Lost
he doesn't have a particularly
big role but we think he definitely
could be a major player
that's because he's Hades son and we all
know that Hades is starring in
descendants three as portrayed by
Cheyenne Jackson and there's plenty of
speculation that Hades will turn out to
be Mao's father in which case Mallon
Haiti would be related they might be
half siblings if Bolivians isn't his mom
too but there's the possibility that
Mallon Haiti could be long-lost twins
wouldn't that be amazing the two do
cross paths in the novel when Mao and
her VK gang turn up at an anti heroes
Club meeting Haiti tears
he tells them he thought their actions
in auradon were really cool and he tells
now that the way she changed in auradon
inspired him and the other Club members
to change their ways so it's clear that
if these two are related they don't know
it what do you think could Haiti and Mao
be siblings so there you have it our
take on why these bill and kids aren't
in The Descendants movies which one
would you most like to see in the films
let us know in the comments section
below thanks for watching make sure to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one we'll see you next time
[Music]